I just completed a webpage and video
series on the Greek miniscule script
found in medieval documents dating from
about AD 850 to 1850 I realized that
some of my readers and viewers might
wish to examine primary manuscripts for
yourselves
fortunately the British library's
digitized collection allows you to do
just that from your own computer up
close and for free and their collection
isn't limited to Greek texts either in
this video I'm going to walk you through
the basic features of their manuscript
viewer I'll also offer some tips to help
you get the most out of your copy
practice if you're learning these
scripts as part of your language or
calligraphy studies if you've had enough
of me and just want to browse the
collection and jump into viewing
manuscripts here's the web address I'll
also put it down in the info bar below
when you visit their page you can browse
manuscripts or search for a specific
document once you've clicked on a
manuscript in its profile page you'll
get a new tab with a manuscript viewer
the top shows the manuscript title and
content description a few key things to
look for here are the original author
the work the year or date range and the
manuscript number below that the main
body of the page is taken up by the
viewer you'll see some handy controls on
the upper right above the image and on
the upper left of the image itself the
controls on the Left allow you to zoom
in and out reset your view via
fullscreen or toggle show or hide
controls the drop-down lists and arrows
on the top right help you navigate
through the entire manuscript the Select
list next to view lets you choose
between viewing a single page open book
view with even pages on the left and odd
pages on the right or or folio view with
odd pages on the left and even pages on
the right finally you'll need a bit more
knowledge to navigate using page numbers
lowercase F stands for folio R means
recto or the front of a page vias verso
or the back of a page
each page number then refers to a whole
leaf not just to one side of a sheet
also notice the British Library copy
right on the bottom of the image
although the text of these manuscripts
may be in the public domain the images
themselves may have a different status
well that's good to get you started I
hope you have fun as you read into the
past and explore some amazing manuscript
treasures
some helpful tips if you will be doing
copy practice in order to learn to write
in these hands I have a few hard-won
recommendations from my many hours of
practice write in a well-lit area adopt
good posture relax your eyes every once
in a while copying can be strenuous
especially when you're new and paying it
close attention to small details zoom in
on the text to see clearly this allows
you to distinguish riding strokes and
lifts of the pen move from the basic to
the tough start with clear legible hands
rather than challenging examples for
example for students of the Greek
minuscule hands I recommend learning the
standard printed minuscule characters
then meet medieval minuscule documents
before you tackle examples like this
look for words you recognize it's like
decoding a puzzle you start with known
values rather than the unknown work with
physical copies whenever possible this
will go further in protecting your eyes
since you may find yourself staring at a
computer screen for hours on end to
imitate even brief texts and finer hands
of course avoid doing anything that will
violate fair use finally enjoy your
pursuit as you participate in a long
history of scribal tradition this is a
wonderful and direct way to learn some
visually stunning scripts as always
thanks for taking the time to learn with
me
you